this series is brought to you by Globe
planets welcome back to part two where
we're going to dive straight in to the
nitty-gritty and I'm going to give you
guys a gift so first of all let's start
by showcasing what that gift is if we
hit the import button go to open you're
going to be able to download this twin
motion tutorial SketchUp file if we open
that up keep all of our settings exactly
the same as you see them on the screen
right now and press import
it's going to process all of that data
and bring in our beautiful house that
we're going to be modeling and playing
with now I'm going to leave a Dropbox
link to this project right here directly
below glow plants in the description so
go download this and keep following on
with tutorial basically once you've done
that what we're going to do is we're
going to select the starting ground like
we learned last time we're going to
select the top arrow and just drag that
starting ground lower until it fully
disappears from our entire project
changing our speed across so we can fly
a little bit quicker because this
project got bigger we don't need this
starting base anymore so I'm simply
going to select the starting base and
hit delete if you fly around to check
out this beautiful house it is a unique
design cancel everything across the
cascading land over the ocean which
would be somewhere over here we'll dive
into that later but in today's tutorial
we are talking about the materiality of
this house how we can make it look
absolutely stunning best practice would
be to actually create the hdri sky first
and select what you want this
environment to look like so then that
way we don't have to go back and
actually change our materials to the sky
so before we dive into materials I will
be diving into hdri Skies first thing
you want to do is simply select your
skies and go into Skies once more
after that your choice you can pick any
of the Skies available to you there's
hundreds and hundreds of options
generally I like a morning and afternoon
sun and generally like it to be either
cloudy or clear I like a darker grayer
Sky to really pop the actual building
out a little bit more and when you shift
through them the little picture appears
on the right hand side and you see how
it affects glass solid and reflective
materials so each one will change the
color of your actual project hence why I
personally recommend it is important to
pick your hdri Sky first now for ease of
use let's simply go back let's go to an
overcast Sky let's pick Sky 10 and all
we need to do is Click left click once
drag it onto your sky and drop it into
your project that will automatically
change adjust and make the scene
significantly nicer now if you wanted to
adjust the actual orientation of that
sky where the Shadows are cast in the
building you'd see the ambience panel on
the right hand side change
and all you'd need to do was scroll down
to hdri Sky and adjust your rotation
panel so however you wanted those
Shadows to be cast on your building you
could simply adjust the rotation for me
personally I'm not too fast I'm not too
bothered it's more about creating the
actual environment getting those colors
right to begin with so let's label that
and not worry about that we'll come to
all of that in another video what we
want to do is come to our materials
palette and we want to go through each
step one by one and really fine tune
these things so let's get started with
glass being the very first material on
our list if we select glass we're going
to have 100 different options completely
up to us which one we choose do I want
clear glass so I can drag drop that
directly into my project and see into my
house from a distance potentially but at
the same time I really like a slight
reflective glass because that way when
you had some clouds into the photos and
into the renders you can see the
reflection of whatever's on the other
side personally I like that I really
enjoy a reflective glance now to make
this glass really stand out we want to
go through a reflective glass material
palette on the right hand side every
single material is going to have
something similar so I'll explain in
detail for glass and then you'll get the
general gist of it for everything else
first of all you have your 3D sphere
that showcases how that object would
actually look in reality you can change
it to standard glass or you can go to
color glass which loses its transparency
completely down below you're going to
have the tint so if I select the tint
you're going to have a Color Picker open
up this Color Picker can occasionally
get hidden behind the project so if at
any point in time you cannot click on
anything twinning motion seems like it's
broken or that it's frozen just move
your window around and see if you can
find this Color Picker bye-bye the Color
Picker very self-explanatory drag it
round change it adjust it if you want
red dark glass you can have that tinted
red glass absolutely disgusting each to
their own and twin motion allows you to
do whatever you want potentially you
might want black dark or even frosted
glass you can change that slightly there
so you get nice black glass you can open
up the details panel and adjust the
sliders as you would in Lightroom but
for now I'm going to keep that closed
opacity is going to be exactly what
you'd expect it to be it's the opacity
of the transparency within the glass and
just like tint you have a few more
little details below you can invert the
mask use opacity Maps get really
intricate and really detailed with your
actual objects but for now we'll keep it
relatively basic we won't overwhelm you
at this point in time continuing to move
down if we had a pattern on our glass so
let's change it to this crazy floral
sticker that I hope nobody puts on an
entire facade of a building like this
you can adjust the rotation along with
the slider and it will adjust that
pattern's rotation you can also adjust
the scale here if you wanted it to be
bigger or smaller it's applicable all
but obviously a lot easier to understand
and comprehend with a pattern shown on
top if you open up the details panel you
can get a bit more control stretch it on
the x-axis stretch it on the y-axis only
offset left and right if you're trying
to align patterns together and if you're
trying to make patterns move you can
adjust them like that so they have some
sort of speed to them in a direction
again you wouldn't have that for a
static but the option is available to
you if you wanted to to be a mirror see
if we drag and drop mirror or go back to
your original reflective glass up top
left it doesn't matter how many changes
you make to this you can always come
back and drag and drop the original back
in now it's always best to just go
through and play with all of these
settings to see how they affect the
project how they affect the material and
what can be done to make the details
look even better for me personally Glass
isn't too bad it's one of those objects
that's pretty decent from the get-go so
I'm happy to leave it as just reflective
glass for the time being
moving back into our materials we can
now dive into our Metals for me
personally in this instance the window
frames would be some fall of metal they
could be a brushed aluminum maybe matte
Chrome or even a habit copper finish
depending what we were looking for being
on the coast it might even be galvanized
steel so if I wanted it to be drag drop
let that go on the window frame now I
definitely don't want it to be
galvanized steel let's scroll back up
let's grab our matte Chrome drag and
drop that over our aluminum frames
scroll back up to our color select the
color palette and then adjust so simply
dragging down is going to change that
from a gray to Black and pressing OK up
close you can see there's not much going
on here it's relatively rough it's not
too smooth it's pretty much in the
middle because roughness is at 50. so if
I drag it back down to zero we'll get
quite a bit of shine quite a bit of
reflection on these window frames it's
up to you if that's what you want or if
you'd actually like it to be a little
bit different so I could easily adjust
that back up and make it back in the
middle of 50. now there are a few
glitches in this model and I do
apologize for that however it was a
quick model to be able to give you guys
something free something that you can
actually learn twin motion with so
whenever you have glitches like this in
the model it basically means two
materials are overlapping if I select
that object right there it's probably
gonna let me move it ever so slightly so
if I pick that go minus 0.01 press OK
fly back in that is going to disappear
because my materials are no longer
overlapping now what you'll notice in
Twin motion with my window frames that
black color was automatically linked to
my roof in Twin motion any colors you
have in your base model so wherever
you've imported it from SketchUp
archicad whatever you're gonna have to
understand that it's going to link
colors together so by having this window
frame is black and the roof is black any
adjustments I make to the window frame
is automatically going to change it to
the roof now because I've unclicked off
that window frame you might be thinking
oh no how do I come back to that well if
you come up to the top you're going to
see this eyedropper tool it's our
material pickup by simply dragging
across anything left clicking it's going
to open up that material that you're
looking for same with this matte Chrome
same as the roof so now if I were to
adjust this slider you'd see the roof
change in the line with my window frames
pressing cancel it will change that back
to how I want it to be and we can
continue working through this design and
the materials the concrete on the
outside is shown as a concrete panel but
really wouldn't be it'd most likely be
some sort of smooth concreted finish it
wouldn't have the concrete panel lines
or not to this extent
so if we come back to our main library
and come into Mega scans this time for a
different material we'll go into
surfaces and we're going to scroll until
we find concrete on the left hand side
Mega scans has so many more options for
us so we can go through these and try
and find the best thing for what we're
trying to articulate if we start with
the slab tool we can scroll through all
the options and see if there's anything
that we really like in this scenario a
cast in situ concrete like this could be
quite nice and I say could because every
material is slightly different so if we
hit that little download Arrow we can
let it download to our computer right
click drag it across before letting go
what you'll notice is all Mega scans
materials and objects will kind of come
in white and pause it's because they're
downloading into your system now for the
first time so now if I Let Go object
creation will happen and we'll see some
sort of formwork now that rotation would
become very important in this scenario
because we need to rotate it so it
aligns perfectly with this but now I
have all sorts of problems because my
model is in a variety of different
angles so that foam board concrete
without going back into the original
model just would insert this project so
if we come back out let's go into smooth
and try to find a beautiful concrete
let's download this concrete floor and
potentially also a few others let's go
smooth concrete wall
concrete sidewalk just download a few to
test out and see what the best options
are for us so let's start with concrete
sidewalk drag drop release grungy it's a
bit grainy but it's a lot of bad
concrete color per se so I'm going to
leave this one as potential maybe as we
scroll through the other options the
smooth concrete is definitely to Bland
and too boring for me but what I could
do is increase some grunge which is
basically aging weathering in the actual
material which would give it a bit more
of the look I'm looking for so that
actually is quite nice in my opinion for
this model
I could then also turn down the
lumiosity which would make it a little
bit darker or a little bit lighter a
little bit more glowing zooming back out
we could potentially see how that
building looks from afar now obviously
it would be amazing to get rid of this
garage move it somewhere else in this
model it just didn't work anywhere else
in this design however if you wanted to
delete it you could go through one by
one and just start tapping the delete
button until eventually you got
somewhere and deleted enough of it that
you were happy with now I'll undo all
that because I kind of want to keep the
garage for the purposes of argument and
for this tutorial so we'll keep that
there but you can delete it all if you
so choose and want to make this even
more powerful of an architectural
statement now for the time being again
I'm relatively happy with this concrete
and I can adjust it continuously as we
move on or I could easily go back to my
sidewalk reduce my scale or increase my
scale to make it something a little bit
different it's probably a little bit too
busy for the sidewalk so I'm going to
keep it as that smooth concrete increase
the grunge
adjust my settings ever so slightly and
there we go now we have a concrete
fascia design that basically will create
an absolute stunning render from almost
any angle looking at it if we wanted to
fly into our house we could simply hit
that eye again go to our pedestrian mode
and it would drop us into pedestrian
mode we can't actually walk through
solid objects anymore which is really
frustrating so pedestrian mode unless
you've got everything set up properly
it's not going to work for you but you
will have a perfectly accessible
pedestrian so if we jump back into drive
mode
fly into our house
now change back into pedestrian mode
we can walk around our house freely
maybe let's reduce our speed back to
three or four so that we can walk around
our house bump into all walls we can't
make it through the doors until we go
back to drone mode but we can see what's
going on in this main space as if we
actually lived here and if you wanted to
mess with the materials on the inside
you could very much do so like this
stone for example needs a little bit of
work needs a little bit of love so if we
go back to our main scan surfaces go
into our marble let's go polished marble
and see what kind of options we have in
stunning polished marble there is many
many options for us including this one's
quite similar to this Stone but maybe
it'll look significantly nicer simply
drag drop let go and there we go we have
a marble Stone top that is pretty much
seamless all the way across and it's a
very nice texture that we can adjust as
we see fit so let's say one a bit darker
a little bit lighter it's all there for
course to mess with play with and adjust
in case you wanted a nice pink Island
bench top you could create that in a
matter of seconds now I'll undo that I
just want to keep it pretty generic
pretty simple going back into drive mode
flying back out to the externals the
materials aren't just for the house
they're also for our environment as well
so let's go back to library let's go
back to materials and let's select
ground what we want to do before we dive
into actually any landscape design which
we'll get into another video we want to
give everything a bit of a base layer so
that we have it something to build on if
we go nature we're going to have a
variety of different Earths and dirts
and Sands and bits and bobs so for
instance I can grab graspive drag and
drop and now I have new grass at the
bottom of my house now if you've ever
asked yourself what is the difference
between a high quality render and an
average render you see all over
Instagram well the difference is the
quality the care and the assets that's
why I've teamed up with globe plans to
be able to give you an incredible
library of the world's best 3D
photorealistic vegetation trees shrubs
and everything in between are these
Globe plans for a very long time now
you've seen them in my videos before and
finally we've come together to be able
to actually bring you a series
worthwhile so if you're looking for some
incredible 3D plants regardless of where
you are situated around the world it
doesn't matter if you're in America
Australia Africa Europe they've got all
of the plants available for every single
person around the globe so make sure you
check out Globe plants in the
description option down below the link
is there for your convenience this sand
down below where Matt want it to be
cracked ground we might want it to be
desert sand maybe something from the
beach we could have a variety of
different options to our hearts content
but for the time being let's just go
some deserts and let's drop that in see
what that looks like from a low angle
like this
you're gonna see the beautiful Peaks and
valleys of the desert sand which will
again adjust or decrease in scale as we
see fit for the purpose of the render
sand is one of those things that has so
many Peaks and valleys so the Sun hits
it in a magnitude of ways and it's quite
challenging to to pick that with a 2d
texture so if we increase our grunge
we're going to start seeing a lot more
darker patches a lot more changes in the
actual moisture so it starts to look a
little bit more real we don't want it to
look too dirty and dark so maybe
somewhere in the 50 we could also slide
our lumens down increase our roughness
so it's a very rough texture now let's
say we wanted to use this material for
the rest of the environment we can
simply select the material pickup select
the material we want to use and instead
of dragging it from the palette and
trying to copy it over and over and over
again we could grab our desert sand drag
and drop it into the environment and
it'll replicate that identical material
for the rest now I don't actually want
that I believe the background would be
much nicer as some sort of grass to
vegetation maybe Mossy ground so
something a little bit darker a little
bit Greener would be lovely I know I'm
gonna have a series of trees this is
basically a forest behind this project
I'm easily just going to grab Forest
ground dirt maybe some cobblestones or
maybe even some ground plant cover drag
and drop it in increase my scale and
make sure from up close that looks
relatively decent now when it comes time
to increase and add all about plants I
can easily drop some beautiful plants in
there last but not least is going to be
our ground and our man-made objects so
for instance this road is the wrong
material for starters we want it to be a
nice little asphalt simply drag and drop
the asphalt in and it's done we can just
make it a bit darker make it a bit
dirtier and it looks a little bit more
realistic now generally speaking if
you're doing a very fine-tuned render
you could go back into live free into
Mega scan surfaces scroll down to the
bottom to Asphalt find a rough asphalt
that was more appealing and potentially
you could have one with lines
automatically built in but because this
shapes and changes and meanders it isn't
just consistently one straight road if I
were to drag rough line markings it
would just be a very messy texture now
one thing I'll point out quickly is that
material linking so because I changed
this to that garden bed it's changed my
actual garden bed in here as well if I
go back ground Back To Nature just
change that Forest covered it will be
more of an earth or a mulch type
material if we want to take it a step
further and actually get really deep
into custom materials well then we could
come down to the bottom here go to our
materials dock find a material that we
really really like let's say we like
this Forest ground but we want to find
something better online or create our
own texture
first of all we need to do is right
click we want to duplicate and then we
want to re-name that material let's
rename it to Earth's tutorial and press
enter now if I select Earth tutorial we
can adjust things to make it even better
let's dive into the details if we drop
down that menu you'll see a textures
embedded image appealer there's
multiples on multiples of different
textured websites out there on the
internet so feel free to use whatever
you can find for the better options
you're going to have to pay for them or
you can try create your custom ones
through simple Googling for the purpose
of this let's jump into Google search
Earth seamless texture so that your
textures align without random joins and
funny objects and find something that
you like it can literally be almost
anything that's free so if you also type
in royalty free it'll give you a few
more images to select from that you can
comfortably know aren't going to be
copyrighted now for the verbs in this
let's literally grab any of these this
appears to be a royalty-free image I'm
not going to dive into it too much it
does look like it's watermarked so I
wouldn't say it is actually free I would
say you'd have to pay for this one if
you're going to use it commercially so
let's pick this cracked Earth one for
just argument right click save to
downloads
close that go back to our twin motion
tutorial click on our texture and let's
go open in your downloads folder you're
going to find that material so simply
press open again
and you'll see that texture immediately
change on the 3D little Globe if we
wanted to drag and drop that over our
sand
and zoom in in C
an incredible textured surface that
could be utilized however you want
increase the scale you'll see it Frac
and pits and change increase the grunge
it gets dirty filthy now it looks like
you're in the middle of the actual
desert so if there is an material that
you can find available to you online or
through the twin motion Library you can
always go ahead and make your own anyway
Dane that's all from me I hope you've
enjoyed it so far I'm gonna bring it in
the playlist to the side of me so if
you're joining me a little bit later you
can find all the content right here
otherwise smash that subscribe button
drop any comments in the description
down below but like always I'll see you
next Monday